foreign
[Laughter]
steps
[Music]
that is
Mommy
[Music]
[Laughter]
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
what's up
foreign
[Laughter]
each other
[Music]
meaning
and welcome back to the realest podcast
in the Dunya the three Muslims again
with the home base how you guys doing
today
so
um I'm going in completely blind I think
we all are going and completely blind to
this reaction I just heard that um sneak
on young Don had a conversation so I
think we should just jump into it
go ahead and show that let's do it all
right
um
let me get this set up
and this window Yeah man so yeah you
know a lot has there's been a lot of
evolution since we last spoke you know
yeah
apparently because uh I preach keeping
the Commandments and all that but you
know
um yeah now and now you are a Muslim
I am yeah okay all right so so talk to
me talk to me you I've I've seen you had
a number of conversations with Muslims
about your conversion have you had any
oh didn't you well I suppose you had a
conversation with Gideon no
yeah we're cheating on and a lot of
other Christians like Nick Fuentes and
there's been uh I've been seeing a lot
of debates and there's been a lot of all
the religious people are reacting to
this stuff so I've been I've been I'm in
tune I've been having a lot of
conversation with people okay all right
yeah so I mean
I'm not here to like you know
the major or anything like that so you
know I mean just tell me tell me
I I think that I have a different
perspective than most Christians it was
not part of uh to convert to Islam
because
Islam actually like follows a lot of the
stuff that I already
grew up with in Catholicism for example
like the most respected woman in the
Quran is Miriam or Mary Jesus's mother
uh she's like number she's mentioned the
most in the Quran and same thing with
Jesus like I just it makes sense to me
that he was a prophet and not the final
Prophet Muhammad peace was a final
Prophet but Jesus was a prophet and he
was delivering God's message but uh
there were things that were
misinterpreted from Christians and I
think Islam corrects a lot of itself so
it's like most of the stuff already
believed in and grew up with uh it seems
like Islam was just the final answer
interesting interesting yeah I mean
like I said brother I didn't I didn't
like
I'm not trying to like the or
anything
um I think a lot of this stuff really
all that a man can do I believe is
present you with an argument and then
it's up to you on your own time to like
evaluate the argument and like take the
various points into consideration
so okay I hear you I hear you but um all
right give me your rundown your
understanding of like what is the point
first of all what is the point of Islam
to you what do you think is the point of
Islam what is the oh what's the end goal
the end goal is to make it into heaven
and I think the word I I don't want to
uh say in this great I think it's um
Janna
so just everything that you do we
believe that everything you do on Earth
is in a sense delayed gratification in
order to be in Eternal Paradise which is
heaven so that means doing a lot of
things that humans don't naturally uh
want to do when it comes to your first
desire or pleasure for example you need
to to wait until marriage and you're not
supposed to put alcohol into your body
you're not supposed to put anything
negative into your body you're supposed
to pray five times a day even when it's
difficult you have to fast even when
it's difficult
um because a lot of things that we do
enjoy like it's night it feels good to
eat a lot of food it feels good to eat
when you want to eat and like first
thing you want to do in the morning
um is drink water but Ramadan exists so
that you can appreciate food more and
you appreciate water more and it's the
ultimate goal is to have a is to worship
Allah so worship God
while we're here because he created
everything and we want to be we're going
to be judged on the final day on the day
of judgment we're going to our actions
are going to be judged and we want to do
what is right while we're here because
you can't take wealth with you can't
take anything else with you the only
thing that you have with you when you
die is your soul and so how intact can
you keep your soul before you die and
the way to do that is to not involve
yourself in worldly pleasures and be a
good person
um
give money away you want to give 2.5
percent of your your money to charity
you want to respect people and
just overall be a good person
let's just pause for a second I was
gonna say that too bro subhanallah he
just put out so much amazing knowledge
it's all 100 accurate and I'm very proud
of him alhamdulillah chat spam W for
that perfect summation near perfect as
much as Nico could have done here
let's continue inshallah yeah yeah I
mean a lot of that stuff is you know it
sounds very honorable sounds very Noble
and I don't have a problem with any of
that stuff you know in fact many of
these kinds of behaviors are encouraged
by God
um through the scriptures
um but if I may can I give you my
understanding of
what Chris what Jesus was like pitching
like to understand so my unders so the
end goal is you go to heaven it sounds
like right and I imagine you go to
heaven in some kind of like a spiritual
disembodied form
is that your understanding
I don't know the exactly what I haven't
finished the Quran but from my
understanding it's like Muslims we don't
really think that we can conceptualize a
lot of these things like we don't think
that it's important to conceptualize God
because we are not capable of
understanding what exactly what God is
like you don't you're not supposed to
draw him you're not supposed to draw
Muhammad upon him or any of the prophets
you're just supposed to uh to be as good
as you can here and then uh you see
Eternal Paradise I'm not sure exactly
how it's um describe it from from what I
understand the rest of Islam it's not
even worth trying to conceptualize so we
don't know
exactly what it what it will look like
or be like
um but it will be internal Paradise
um
okay what's your opinion on the on the
Trinity what's your explanation for that
and do you think two questions like one
how do you describe the Trinity and two
do you think that Jesus is God yeah no I
don't believe in the Trinity and I don't
I so here's the thing God is a person
right we have a Creator An Almighty the
father he created all things his name is
Yahweh right and Islam you you refer to
him as a law but Allah believes just
um
um Arabic for for God so it's like
calling him God right so that's not his
name dude in Islam is does God have a
name
no just a lot okay all right so in the
Bible right in the book of Exodus which
is a part of the Torah which I believe
Muslims in Islam recognize as you know a
um accurately preserved portion of the
scriptures I think Muslims particularly
have a problem with the New Testament
but they don't re I've heard him
criticize the Old Testament that much so
as far as I'm aware they acknowledge the
writings of Moses have you heard
anything otherwise to that
I think that's correct but there there's
a lot of criticism in the Quran about
the way that Jews conduct business and
credit especially like credit and
interest all that's Haram uh and
everything and um in the Kabbalah and
the talmud like all the mysticism and
stuff that's completely Iran but yeah
you know it's interesting what have you
heard about the Jews and how they
conduct inter like they charge interest
well if you look into the talmud
there's our if you even look in the
Kabbalah there's a lot of there's some
verses where they talk about it's not a
sin to lie to like they don't think
that you can lie to because they're
the chosen people and they see others as
the that's all nonsense you know it is
right you know that's none of that is
scripture right
none of that scripture a lot of this is
stuff that like isn't really it's hard
to find like you could just find quotes
like apparently it's just
um shared between rabbis and stuff yeah
so all of that you know again this is so
if you read the gospels right Matthew
Mark Luke and John the first four books
of the Bible these are the books that
document
um the life the ministry of Jesus right
or Yeshua uh Yeshua or Jesus was very
much against he was con the people he
fought against the most were the Jewish
rabbis at the time the the the Pharisees
they were called Pharisees right now
people call me a Pharisee people don't
know what Pharisees are right
um Jesus condemned the Pharisees because
they were not keeping the Commandments
they were not preaching the Commandments
of God but instead they came up with
their own rules their own sense of right
and wrong that were that was inspired by
The Commandments of God and this is no
different than what we see in you know a
lot of modern day Christianity as well
um but we also see the same thing in
Islam right taking the Commandments of
God and changing it building upon it
tweaking things for instance in the in
Islam you guys have a Sabbath right
no we don't
um I don't I wouldn't say Sabbath now
okay I thought you I thought in Islam
they had a Friday Sabbath uh is that a
thing no no I mean on Friday men are
required to go to the Majid and pray
Juma but there's no Sabbath
um that
oh I don't I'm about to Google it right
now but I don't think so oh okay all
right well anyway anyway yeah so the
Trinity yeah brother I don't I don't
agree with the doctrine because the
Quran states that since the Sabbath was
only for Jews Muslim replace Sabbath
I'll rest with Juma so yeah this is uh
juman prayer oh okay all right yeah so
again you know the the father gave us
the Sabbath there's a reason we have a
seven day week right this is a this is
something you don't find anywhere else
but in the Bible right in the Torah the
establishment of a seven day week this
is all this is there's a reason why the
whole world operates under this like
um system and it's because it was what
was established with the first people
and so of course this carried on
um into every culture that came after
Adam and Eve and the seventh day is the
Sabbath day and it's a day of rest but
um so yeah with the Trinity I don't
subscribe to the doctrine of the Trinity
brother it is uh it is not a doctrine
that one need the Bible required the
Bible doesn't teach a trinity there is
not a single verse or a single section
in the Bible that attempts to teach the
concept of the Trinity the Trinity is a
is a doctrine that is derived from
various verses in the Bible and and
people Full Assault uh philosophize it
right they say oh well if this is if I
understand this verse like this and I
combine them together what you get is
the concept of the Trinity but you can't
find a single verse where Jesus or any
of the Apostles or the Apostle Paul
attempts to teach the concept of Yahweh
being a being consist you know three
different persons yeah I'm getting a lot
more work done I'm way more optimized
and converting to Islam has been I would
say it's been really good for my for my
mental
um there there is one thing I don't know
if you read this in the Bible
saying that I've seen versus shake with
mom showed me like that Jesus would
there's a verse where it says Jesus
would pray and put his head to the floor
um praying to God and that's like that's
pretty much how that's how Muslims pray
you you put your your face down and you
touch your forehead to the to the prayer
mat
Let's uh let's take a brief from break
because I think they're moving on to a
different topics so so far I have a few
thoughts
firstly um I think uh sneak was doing an
amazing job so far alhamdulillah I do
want to answer something that a young
Don brought up which was the idea that
like we almost accept the Torah or we
don't have too much scrutiny towards it
but the New Testament we do there is a
level of Truth to that because Allah
doesn't even mentioned in the New
Testament it's not worth mentioning the
New Testament he doesn't mention the
Bible he says the Torah and the gospel
so basically that which was revealed to
Moses and that which was revealed to
Jesus peace and blessing to be upon both
of them so there is a level to
um Authority maybe you could say on the
Torah because it's maybe some parts of
it go directly back to Moses in a way
that the gospels you know might not go
back to Jesus
but Allah mentions many times in the
Quran something along the lines of you
know woe to those who write this
scripture with their own hand and claim
that this is from God you know and we
believe that this is what the Jews did
this is what the the people who claim to
be inspired by God did the people who
were in charge of preserving these books
that's exactly what they did and I mean
just look at the new sorry the Old
Testament itself you'll see many stories
of how prophets disobeyed God and many
things that you don't really think you
would find in a holy in Holy Scripture
like the size of someone's genitalia
like this is really something God would
put in a scripture or is it more likely
the case that men who are a little
jumped in and had a Thor the authority
to change what was in it or lie about it
or what they say about the the size of
the genitalia stuck with a lot of them
is actually it's something along the
lines of I don't want to say it because
it was it bde and lde
I don't know what those mean
just um but yeah it's like it's a very
very bad stuff a lot like it's the size
of a donkey and like all this horrible
stuff
um do you really think that you know God
Allah
the creator of the universe would put
something like that in the scripture or
is it more likely that men interfered
and put that stuff in I think it's very
clear
no
whether it's accepted or not or what
degrees accepted to if we if Muslims can
even read it or not that's the debate
amongst Muslim Scholars if you're
allowed to read it or not
um but majority of Scholars they give it
no real Authority like it doesn't
affect how we live our life oh let's go
see what God told Moses you know we just
go to the Quran and the son of the
Prophet peace upon him for what to
believe in how we live life
man I just want to jump in and say
that I love both of these brothers for
the sake of Allah if I sneak over man
this he's already learning so much
and you can tell and he's actually
proper in it
and then young Don bro for the fact that
he is looking for the answers
you know because if if he had not been
he would have not gotten to the
conclusions he's gotten to as if as of
yet as of so far
like to to denounce the Trinity as a
Christian
boy you know he's getting here for that
you won't be a crucified for that bro
foreign
I want to say just keep going
you know because
if he eventually sees that there have
been
like alterations within the Bible
then he'll start to understand even more
because
there are pieces are so many pieces of
the puzzle within Christianity
so many pieces of the puzzle within
Judaism
but the poem is is that because there
has been alterations we we cannot know
what is
real versus what is not real
when you have the scholars going in to
study and they have to know right off
the rip that it has been altered before
they even go like deeper into the
studies
so when you understand that and you
understand that every single Prophet
that has come down
if you no longer see Jesus as
God you see him as like okay he was
bringing the message he was trying to
bring everyone to God to the father he
was saying the father
if every single profit came with the
same message there was only one God
be a good person
then now you can understand
even more the texts that are being
you know written in the the Bible
this is one thing that says in the Bible
supposedly that
the only way to the father
is through me
to follow me
and a lot of Christians take the other
context and we'll say that ah
he said this therefore Jesus Is God
therefore this is the only way that I'm
gonna you know go to heaven I have this
is it this is it I have to say that he's
he's the Lord and he's a savior and all
this
but no if all prophets came with the
same message
then were you to follow any of the
prophets
you will go to heaven you will go to the
fault it will go to Allah to God why
because they were all
spreading the same message
there's only one God worship this one
God and be a good person
so that same line that's in the Bible
we can apply that same thing to the
prophet Muhammad peace be upon him
if you follow the prophet Muhammad peace
be upon him
he will go there then you will go to
Allah why because he is only
leading you to what is good for you to
what is righteous
to what is the best thing for you in
this life and in the next yeah so again
I really do love these Villages and I
love the
the development that I'm seeing from
young dumb and for real
I'm talking about it bro that was a very
succinct explanation I want to give a
huge shout out to Sheikh with or whoever
whichever brother or sister decided to
name that channel one message Foundation
such a fitting name so perfect and it
makes me wonder like as Muslims bro we
believe that if you are a non-muslim
it's possible you could go to Jannah
definitely it doesn't mean all
non-muslims are going to go to you know
how far but as a Christian they believe
that unless you believe that Jesus is
God and he died for our sins and
whatever yadda yadda you're gonna be
doing for eternal hell how does that
mean like does that not problematic bro
is that not extremist to the point where
you either believe that or original sin
takes over and you go to Hellfire and no
matter what you do no matter how Pious
you are no matter your deeds and your
wrongdoings the belief is all that it
takes
yeah that's a great point I love both of
you guys
I think inshallah we should
get right back to the reaction then
Bible you see various people when they
are praying I mean you gotta think about
it when you bow down on the ground you
are physically humbling yourself to the
greatest degree and so we see examples
of Moses King David you know various
people from the Bible you know Elijah
praying in this prone position it's not
like that in church
I don't know I mean in some Churches
they do get down on their knees right
they get down on their knees on the pews
like in Catholic churches in particular
I've been to I've been not not on the
floor like you get on the Pew kind of
but you're still standing like this but
it's not on the on the actual floor it
seems if most people could admit that
that's the the strongest form of
submission if you're going to submit to
to anything it should be to to God I'm
confused about that it doesn't make
sense to me like why because you just
sansit kind of kneel on the thing but I
pray I I do all I do everything bro I'll
pray I'll just be walking somewhere and
do a little quick praying my head or
I'll could be my my closet in my walk-in
closet door closed I'll be on the floor
forehead to the ground praying to God
it's it's re it's like that's the thing
it's not a commandment in terms of the
position you take when you're praying
but when you realize that you are
praying to your creator who is sitting
above you in his throne in heaven you
know
it feels like a very you know um
appropriate position to take when coming
before the almost pause
you know there's I just wanted to say
that bro and slightly deviant man look
at him to Islam but many Muslims don't
even know where Allah is located bro
subhanallah
yeah let's not let's not open up that
discussion now
alhamdulillah bless I'm forgetting that
right yeah
I mean yeah but here's the thing at the
end of the day what matters is you know
the genuineness of your prayer and you
know your relationship with God see it
doesn't matter if you get on the floor
and put your head to the floor if you're
not having a genuine conversation with
your creator you know what I mean so
that's really what we we care about but
I I you know I think it's a good thing I
think it's a good thing to pray you know
in that prone position because it makes
you very humble but you're not always in
a in a place to do that you see here's
the difference though between like maybe
you might have been in airports and seen
Muslims doing that I don't know if
you've ever seen that in the Arab world
they even have sections where you can go
and pray off to the side in an airport
like prayer room specifically yeah see
what something Jesus prayed or preached
against is praying in a public fashion
praying in a way for people to see that
you're praying so here uh there are a
lot of Christians who will get down into
their hands and knees and pray privately
in their bedroom or in their closet you
know what I'm saying but who are you who
who are you making a show for if God is
all knowing
we don't make it a show it's just that
when you're out or you're working you're
in a place where you can't find a
private place available then yeah then
you do it in public like some you'll see
people working at Halal restaurants and
they'll put the prayer man next to their
food card for example but that's only
because of that out of proximity you
know and there's nothing else available
so that's a good exception to the rule
you know if you have no if you have no
private place then you might it's better
to pray than not pray but obviously
that's not like there's no part in the
Quran where since you're putting on a
show that's to see I mean that's
something that's very similar between
you know what Jesus taught allegedly and
what Muslims believe Jesus is not saying
like it's prohibited for you to pray in
public he's just making a point that you
shouldn't show off for people you
shouldn't pray in public so that people
can say wow what a Pious person and
they're they're you know there's a lot
of that in in Islam either in the Quran
or in this it's very clear that when you
do an action they're buying their
intentions all right so if you do an
action for the sake of people looking at
you and thinking you're high and mighty
or you're some amazing person then the
only reward you're gonna get is maybe
those people thinking you're cool but
you're not going to be rewarded by Allah
you might actually be punished because
you're basically praying for them to
recognize you rather than praying for
Allah so very similar Jesus seems to be
preaching things that as Muslims we
would 100 agree with
I I hear you I feel you so okay in Islam
you have to pray
in your chair
what it sounded like Don responded to
you after you uh I wish man done bro my
brother you're always invited Don was
done was watching her stream a few weeks
ago so yeah he needs to get uh an assist
I don't know if it was like a pastor or
priest or somebody yeah done get your
whole Squad and let's do it
or just pull up by yourself man we'll
have a nice discussion you know we don't
need your debate or anything
sure I mean you just in your head real
quick do a prayer to God like just
speaks in your you know with your
internal voice of God they make
exceptions too if you're like an old man
or you're disabled then you can sit in a
chair if you can't actually get to the
floor but that's what you're supposed to
do uh obviously that was on a plane
coming back from Morocco and the flight
attendant was Muslim and he would you
know he had no space to get on the floor
so he's had a prayer sitting down but
you're supposed that's how you're
supposed to pray like anything else is
just because you don't have the option
to interesting interesting yeah see
that's one thing I would you know I
think you could make the argument for I
mean it's subjective at the end of the
day but I think that's something you can
make the argument for when it comes to
Christians is this idea that okay if
you're in a public place if it is a
genuine prayer and you do like if you do
a prayer in your head real quick right
you're going into something and you just
pray to the father in your head that is
the most genuine form of prayer where
nobody ever else knows you're doing it
not like no the only reason you're doing
it is because you believe that he's
listening you know what I mean because
you believe someone's listening as
opposed to you know
um doing it in a more public fashion so
I can see why I think I'm getting pretty
caught up on the on the public fashion
thing because maybe that's how you've
seen it I think it's good to pray in
your head like that like if you're
walking around but in Islam prayer is
taken extremely seriously that's the
first thing you're supposed to do after
you take your shahada which is just
admitting that Allah Creator and
Muhammad peace behind was a final
Prophet I have to take a shot of the
most important thing is to get the
prayers right and so there's a lot of
things that won't your prayer won't be
accepted for example if you just
fornicated and you don't clean yourself
then the prayer is not accepted so like
we do this thing called Voodoo before
you pray if you're if you're dirty at
all like you're supposed to there's a
foster specifically you get to clean
your feet clean your hands clean your
mouth nose ears you're supposed I just
want to give a quick disclaimer it's not
just fornicated even if you had
intercourse with your wife permissively
you still can't pray
we clean everything around
um it's supposed to be completely clean
before you pray so that you're there's
nothing like obstructing your body
because even like things in the Quran
like you're not supposed to to talk or
you're not supposed to get distracted
during prayer you're not supposed to
like even like things like pass gas
stuff like that like if you you can't
interrupt that when you're praying it's
just you and you're just supposed to to
worship God and nothing is supposed to
interrupt that at all so cleanliness is
extremely important and uh and being
fully focused and if you're not then the
prayer doesn't count I think I want to
pause here that's honestly such a
beautiful point and again Secrets come a
long way may Allah bless him I just want
to make a quick distinction and and
Christianity you don't seem to have any
prayer like we have Salah
so when we say prayer in English it's
just prayer but there's Salah and
there's Dua in Arabic they're both a
prayer but they're different types of
prayers is supplication you supplicate
to Allah you ask Allah you talk to Allah
you praise Allah you ask Allah for
forgiveness all this stuff you can do it
sitting down lying down standing running
jogging in your head out loud in your
heart like whatever Salah is as um
this the sister says here is a ritual
obligation may Allah bless you beat me
to it Salah is a ritual obligation that
we are commanded to to follow five times
a day Dua is just a supplication so it
you know everything the Christians do
when they're walking in their heads and
Muslims can do that as well but on top
of that we have Salah we have the ritual
obligations and you can there are many
blessings you can derive from that many
reasons and wisdoms you know Unity
between fellow muslims praying together
discipline and consistency
for every individual who maintains their
five daily Salah Salah literally means
it comes from the root word which means
to connect or a connection which means
you as an individual are connecting with
your Lord because you're praying in the
exact way he told you to in the exact
motions the exact words you know just
think about what you say people just see
actions they don't know what you say
all praise is to Allah
the Lord of of everything that exists
the worlds the universe the everything
that exists
the most gracious the most merciful
owner of the day of judgment
you alone we worship and you alone we
ask for help
keep us on the straight pathology
keep us on the straight path not the
path of those who have earned your anger
and not the path of those who have went
astray and then amen basically how
beautiful is that where you recite that
like 17 times a day you know ask
praising God asking God for guidance
asking God to keep us on a straight path
and not on the path of those who have
earned his anger or went astray
what more could you could you want from
from your Lord in this life
this is why especially when you look at
it from a theological perspective the
the translation prayer for Salah is a
little limited it's more than that it's
it's worship
yeah and this kind of goes back to what
young dong was saying were
you know you can pray every single time
and this is true yes you can pray at
every single time but if we are
understanding that Dua is essentially
the same thing as you know the normal
prayer that Christians do
is like
a little break
you taking a little break and you're
supplicating to the Creator you're
asking a creator for something
when you do Salah
you're disconnecting first from the
entire world
and then you're leaving the world
and when you leave the world and you're
fully focused and that's Allah
like the connection that you feel is
it's it's not you can't compare that to
just a simple Dua
you know the Dua after Salah
it hits completely different
the Dua I like a random time throughout
the day
it will never hit its horn as a doer
either after Salah or while you have
your head on the ground and you're
prostrating in Salah so literally the
definition
it means connection linguistically means
connection
literally like this is the most
I'd say the most
I don't know the most simplest form I
guess you could say the most realist way
of understanding what it is when you
experience it yourself you you can
definitely attest to it
yeah 100 and um I want to preemptively
also add that Allah says in the Quran
that he says seek
um seek help through patience and prayer
and he says Salah prayer Salah
and then he says it's a burden except
for those who are humble right it's a
burden to everyone except those who are
humble which means if you find it to be
a burden that you have to pray whether
you're in public or in private or
whatever if it's a burden because you're
an arrogant person because you're not
humble enough to obey God just to pray
like literally in the whole day it's
like 25 minutes you guys watch uh one
episode of whatever TV show you watch is
longer than that and you can't pray to
God for that long every single day like
come on guys you guys are crazy if you
think it's a burden sometimes we gotta
take a step back around me and we gotta
ask ourselves these questions like why
are we praying in the first place
because many people don't realize that
they just do these things in a habitual
ritualistic manner without taking a step
back and being present so I believe
there's a Hadith where the Prophet saws
mentions that Allah doesn't need the
heedless supplication
just like there's another Hadith with
Prophet saws mentions that Allah doesn't
need the fast of somebody that is not
going to refrain from fellow speech
during the day so like generally
understanding why are we doing what
we're doing there's a specific manner
there's a specific mindset that we have
to have it's not just something you know
okay my phone app you know Avon app or
whatever goes off until it's time for us
and now we just pray also then we're
back to it and we just you know go up
and down like it's some type of like
Plyometrics but we gotta ask ourselves
why are we doing this what is this
connection
100 exactly that's a beautiful point and
I want I think everyone should just
you know take a minute to reflect on
that during the stream pause it whatever
you know go reflect on it or after the
stream reflect on it even young Don you
know like like reflect on it for a bit
imagine God himself gave you exact words
to use and exact motions to to go
through in a prayer and said do this for
me every single day if God came and told
you that you would treat it with honor
because I know you're a good man you
would treat it with honor and you would
uphold it for the rest of your life
inshallah and that's exactly what
Muslims do we have exactly what Allah
wants from us and we don't
want to even miss a bit of it you know
we don't we don't want to miss it even
by like an Adam's weight
because every Adam's weight will be
accounted for
um
so crazy every time fire speaks his
audio is so much louder than yours Rami
and then when I look at Fire's video he
has his light right here and every every
time I see the light I always think
there's like a volume bar and I'm trying
to click it to like put the volume down
but it's not
[Laughter]
that's funny inshallah I'll hopefully
improve my audio very soon um but what
you guys think we should watch a video
in this format or should we go back to
this format
number I like the the one we had
like this one
I think when we're responding
is this should be bigger when we're
responding yeah yeah when we're
responding I think it's cool when we're
bigger but when we're watching might as
well put the attention onto the thing
you know yeah all right let's get back
to it yeah okay yeah no that's
interesting that's interesting I was
just giving you a Different Light
perspective on like why you know you can
there can be a benefit to not doing the
whole
um you know
going prone as a Christian when you when
you take when you look at it from the
perspective of oh this is just a private
like communication between you and God
but I I I I don't have any problem with
it
I'm not I'm not suggesting that my
Muslims pray in public in prone that
they're doing it for the sake of showing
other people that they're so religious
you know what I'm saying you know um I'm
not accusing anyone of that I don't
think I I personally I don't think
Muslims are doing it for that reason I
don't think that that's uh there's
nothing that makes it seem like that I I
don't think that if they were thinking
that while they were praying it wouldn't
be accepted
yeah yeah you know so so yeah it's I'm
just giving you you know my perspective
on the whole prayer posture thing but
okay okay and um all right so he's not
debating though gone to Spain looking
for a wife
rumble's getting you good
um you know okay all right well
and you're telling me that I should
react to a rat race that's your yeah
okay it's only on Twitter you say it's
also on your Rumble page right so yeah
but I'm posting like these uh the more
edited ones on Twitter because Twitter
um have a pretty pretty big presence on
it's a good platform right now the video
player is getting better a couple other
things I just came to mind like prayer
and uh in Islam
um I like what I really like why because
because I'm new to it like when you pray
in a Masjid you're supposed to like
stand shoulder to shoulder with
everybody and I didn't really understand
that at first and it's not even like
you're like squishing each other but
your shoulders are supposed to be like
touching a little bit next to the people
there and it's because you're creating a
wall against shaytan you're blocking the
devil from being able to to interrupt
the prayer so everyone stands there and
there's other things like um
just like about the hand positions
you're supposed to keep the hands here I
I like it's
I personally have felt like a stronger
connection praying uh in Islam like a
type of connection that I that I I
didn't really uh feel in Christianity
yeah I mean here's the thing here's
here's my uh argument for Christian
prayer uh as opposed to Islamic prayer
you know
Jesus spoke against uh vain repetitions
you know he spoke against memorized even
the Lord's Prayer I do not believe is a
this like memorized prayer that we're
just supposed to recite I think God
would
um you know was showing us through Jesus
how to speak to him you know what I mean
like the format but I think what God
wants is a genuine conversation a
genuine relationship a genuine like you
it'd be like imagine if you you know
every time you linked up with a homie
friend a girl and you just like said the
same thing every time yeah
I had that apprehension at first too but
as you start getting because you're
supposed to always repeat certain
phrases When you pray at the different
times of day but it's not like you're
you're just saying that to Allah you're
you're reciting the prayer but in that
moment when you're reciting it that's
when you're having a conversation it's
not like you're saying the words it's
like it's not like when you say they are
our father 10 times after the priest
tells you to do any confession it's not
like you're saying that directly you're
the thoughts that you're having and the
connection that you're having you are
having a conversation with god that's
separate from what you're just reciting
so even though you're saying things that
that you repeat every single time over
and over again I I felt like when I'm in
the Majid praying or when I'm praying at
home that in that moment of repetition
that's when I I really see what's going
on in my head and what I'm saying to God
and what what I uh resonate with more in
Islam is when I was praying in
Christianity like when I was a kid uh I
would ask for a lot I would be like I
want this I want that please give me
this please do that
um and when I pray in Islam I don't know
if this is correct but it's more like
I'm showing gratitude and
more appreciative of what I have and I I
don't feel the um when I'm praying I'm
not asking I'm not saying I want this
I'm grateful and I'm praying and I'm
appreciative of the people around me and
my loved ones and everything and hoping
that if I do the right things or when I
do the right things that everybody will
be okay so it's more just
um it's more gratitude in the in the
prayer
for me
man that was so beautiful honestly that
was so beautiful I am subhanallah I
guess that was what I was alluding to
before when I mentioned what we say and
what we mean when we recite the Quran
when we're praying
and
that's that's the thing and I really
appreciate what sneako said that we're
not just asking God we're praising God
there are certain things in life that we
need to be reminded of every day or we
we need to be reminded of certain things
every day we need to live with certain
mentalities and certain beliefs so
something like just the first thing you
say when you begin your prayer when you
say Allahu Akbar what does that mean it
means God is greater and people say that
like you're basically throwing
everything behind you you know God is
greater God is greater than my stress my
worries my problems my issues my family
my money my work anything God takes
presidents over it God is greater than
all of it so you start your prayer
without with that mentality God is
greater
and then you basically go into the
recitation I I mentioned earlier the
translation I'm not going to repeat it
again but you praise God and then you
ask God for guidance and so on and so
forth
things that are blessings in life you
say praises to the Lord the most great
you you prostrate with your head on the
floor and say when your head is at the
lowest point right the highest point of
your body is on the lowest point of the
Earth currently that you can reach and
you're saying praises to the Lord the
most high so when you're at your lowest
you say praises to the Lord the most
high these are things that are so
humbling that are so beautiful that
you know all of of quraish the the
people who are enemies of the process
when he recited some of the Quran they
all did what they all prostrated and put
their head to the dirt to the floor
because that's something that is natural
for human beings when they recognize the
greatness of their lord and that is what
Muslims get out of Salah and if you
don't then you know that that is your
own shortcoming and that is something
you need to work on and build your
relationship with Allah
W tension
foreign
you
five anything else guys you guys want to
jump in I'm the love bro it's been a
while since I seen you smile like the
Miller keep putting note on your face
llama I mean and for all of us I mean
bro no I mean I think it's only right
that once we have wrapped up the
reaction we do a little bit of quick q a
for anything directly pertaining to what
we talked about today anything relevant
inshallah
we were supposed to but
this brother is nowhere to be found male
uh make it easy on him probably an
emergency or anything like that because
he was looking forward to it and he was
a subscriber he's Italian I believe he
accepted Islam
so Angela will have a monsoon even if
it's on today
in Charlotte sounds good
um I would love to speak with the young
Don I spoke to him a few times recently
alhamdulillah and for everyone who's won
a remade officer you know made up with
him on behalf of all of us and three
Muslims and and he's I honestly think
he's a great guy alhamdulillah he has
come a long way he has grown a lot as
have we alhamdulillah and uh you know
same thing with snickle so of course we
invite Snickers always and we invite
young Don to come and have a nice
discussion
um if he wants to bring like expert
versus expert we can arrange that if he
just wants to have conversation with us
we can do that as well and we can
explain to him why
you know even though we've seen
Christianity I heard Christianity and
maybe read parts of the Bible or read
the Bible why we prefer Islam and our
reasoning behind that and you mentioned
something important that you know the
best thing that men can do is give his
best argument right or hear whatever
argument someone brings and then reflect
on it and I agree 100 so this is Allah
says you know if you believe there are
Gods aside from Allah then bring forth
your proof bring your evidence so we
this is what we stand by as well and I
would love to have a nice conversation
um with all the fear Muslims and young
Don as well insha Allah
so this is why I said earlier that I
love them both for the sake of Allah
because man looking at his
development in this whole journey it
shows that he's
he's a True Believer and he's actually
looking for the truth yeah you know so
may Allah make it easy for him to find
exactly what he's looking for I mean
because the first Stepping Stone from
trinitarianism is to be a Unitarian
Christian
and then inshallah we can make the next
step very soon if Allah was inshallah
you know one of the things people were
saying to him when he denounced the
Trinity is is Young Don you're a Muslim
now you're a freaking Muslim how dare
you I've so I find it funny that that's
that's what they turn to when they think
of Unitarianism but I don't know
I think we should take some some
comments inshallah uh we're we're we all
are lacking in knowledge but we can
admit our flaws and just come together
and understand the love of God and what
he truly wants inshallah
then this is where we have to understand
that
like calling people to gun people to
Allah calling people to Islam
it cannot be done with aggression it
cannot be done with anger with animosity
or with any ounce of arrogance it just
doesn't work this way
you know like imagine trying to tell
someone about God but then when they
tell you why they don't believe or they
tell you why they are not following
Islam
you're getting upset at them
and telling them oh you understand that
the way that you believe is is like the
disbelievers and you're gonna go
straight to hell this is how you believe
like are you serious you think this
person is going to respond to something
like this
we have to be
more mindful
in our approach
absolutely
Muslims Corner yes I think but they said
that Allah will some part of himself and
their judgment and truly knows obviously
how that will be so this whole
discussion is um something that I think
we should avoid in the comment section
especially because um there's no point
in you know starting any kind of fire or
argument in here and this is something
that I think a lot of people get really
hooked on arguing about
so let's stick to the main point
inshallah and for Christians I think
it's a point that we we remind ourselves
that Allah says in the Quran to
basically come to terms with people of
the book that you worship one God alone
so at the end of the day
even with young Don and injury on the
Unitarian Christians we can come to
terms that we we worship one God alone
and that we both want to please God and
follow God and whatever he revealed for
us to follow and for us to practice and
I I genuinely think that insha Allah one
day both Judy on and young Don will see
the truth in Islam
um whether they accept her or not is up
to them but I know that they are very
sincere people
from what I can see and I generally
think that if they are given dawa and
they take the time to have these
discussions that they will see the truth
in Islam inshallah even through the
Bible even through the Old Testament and
and what we can see from Jesus in the in
the Gospels
ignoring realizing what
when someone stops trying
to give dawah that's when they really
start giving though
I mean
so
I just I'm reflecting right now I'm
reflecting the times when I was trying
to give dawah
and I was just it couldn't have worked
with what I was trying to push and I was
like just
like two off the top with it too
passionate about it like trying to shove
it down someone's throat
whereas like once I stopped for a long
time trying to give dog because I I
thought of myself and I was like no I I
don't have the authority to give though
I don't have the intelligence I don't
have the knowledge over Islam to be
giving Dao what am I doing
and I just made the intention to instead
just get closer to Allah get closer to
God
that's when the dollar started that's
when the real dollar started that's
completely like a Sidetrack has nothing
to do with what you were saying I was
just reflecting on it I thought it was a
great reflection I had on yeah I I agree
100 I think that's an amazing point and
just to kind of pick it back off that I
think I think the reason is because of
sincerity you know if you look at the
prophet salaam one thing he had that I
think a lot of people like is genuine
care and genuine like sincerity because
it's not just care in the sense that
he's careful with what he what he says
to people and how he says that and he's
cognizant of their feelings it's not
like he genuinely cares about people you
know the people who hated him he you
know he was actually holding some of
their stuff in their house because they
trusted him enough to take care of their
belongings and they knew that he would
give it back to them these are the same
people that were persecuting him and and
persecuting Muslims so he took care of
their stuff in his own home that's how
much he cared about them and I think a
lot of Muslims unfortunately like that
today which sucks but as soon as you do
what you mentioned you know stop trying
to get down one and really just force it
and push it on them you begin to see
them as a human being you begin to
really care about them and when that
happens people feel that sincerity and
whether people want to admit it or not
just like you wouldn't listen to someone
who's being harsh and hateful
you will listen to someone who's being
sincere kind genuine and you can tell
really cares about you whether you're
you're cognizant of that or not I think
that's one of the best things people can
do when they speak to non-muslims
it's 100 man
uh comments going off about of all
certain people I just read like three
horrible comments this is the stuff like
that bro what do you think you're doing
when you do stuff like this
you think you're you're making people
get closer to God to Allah you think
you're making Muslims want to learn more
about Islam and get closer to Allah or
do you think you're creating
division Fitness
unfortunate
bro this is actually very important
I actually saw this I forgot where I saw
this but it was about reverts
and they were saying how
a lot of times a lot of rivers leave
Islam
because of the people that are speaking
like this yeah the people that are too
extreme the people that are too harsh
the people that are cut throat and
they're trying to push things down your
throat pause and this come on bro like
it's a sad thing when you see
people who consider themselves Muslims
it they're speaking like this they're
acting like this like do you understand
what a Muslim means it means you're
submitting to God with someone who
submits to God speak like this
someone who's submits to God act like
this
hey we're not perfect
but come on yeah and you know you make a
great point because what does Allah say
in the Quran he says that basically when
the ignorant address you and you know
harshly
respond with with uh Salam basically you
know peace or words of peace
to those who are ignorant and harsh and
hateful you know respond with peace or
in in words of Peace Allah commanded
Musa and speak kindly
you know that's for a reason was a
detestable horrible person he was
disgusting he was you know offering
children infants based on the dream he
had he was a horrible Tyrant the
enslaved an entire nation of people 12
whole tribes of people
subhanallah so you know for Muslims the
character good character is one of the
most important things
was sent to as you said perfect good
character he said that character good
character is is one of the heaviest
things on the scale
so this is not something that as Muslims
we take lightly even the smallest things
and this is why I think Islam is so
beautiful beyond any other way of life
or any other religion it focuses on
things that really benefit people like
if I have good character you will be
more receptive to the goodness and and
you will reciprocate my kindness a lot
of the time and even if you don't at
least I'm not amplifying the the anger
or the harshness that you feel and now
if you overstep as a Muslim I'm also
told to combat it with that which is
equal and fair and if you inclined
towards peace I'm told to also incline
towards peace there's so much Beauty
and and and a beautiful balance with the
Islamic way even when dealing with
people and that's what I love about
Islam
Hadith mentioning that Islam was set for
nothing except to perfect our manners
bro you don't have yeah if we don't have
good manners nothing else matters
I don't know about that last part but
the first part definitely is a Hadith
I mean strictly from a double
perspective real matters is extremely
important
whether people like to admit it or not a
lot of these so-called you know you want
to be a daddy you think you know
ideologically you hold Superior values
to let's say another Muslim I agree with
you I'm with you 100 but how you convey
that how you share that how you go into
discourses with people as a
representative of the dean of Allah this
is extremely important bro almost to the
point where sometimes how you say things
matter more than what you say
that's extremely powerful and dangerous
and scary because sometimes you gotta
realize what you say is the truth
but if falsehood is veiled around good
manners good etiquette
you know
like isn't that dangerous bro
yeah and if truth is if truth is veiled
with harshness like on house saying to
cut through lack of empathy emotional
intelligence
then people won't give a value so how
are you even going to get the true
message into the door
yeah
that's a great point
and it's a great lesson for Muslims
what other questions are on the board
first I wanna I wanna address something
that one guy said Slavic Slavic drill
um
oh he's back
oh he's been here before
it's okay I mean we'll deal with
whatever he says so then he says
Muhammad
wasn't perfect
um Merry Little Child
having sex slaves and and offing people
is perfect he asks so firstly you see
how these people have to assert things
that are not true about the prophet
peace be upon him
in order to try and combat stem bring
one true piece of information and bring
your evidence for it and then inshallah
we can have a conversation to deal with
this what as a child someone who has not
hit puberty he never you know married by
the way married has two meanings married
could be like a contract and ceremonies
done married could also mean consummated
so when I say Merit I mean I'm married
proper consummation everything he didn't
marry someone who's not a child because
as we have the narrations was old enough
secondly there's no such thing as an uh
sex slave in Islam these are people who
are prisoners of War
and you're not allowed to force yourself
onto the women but Allah
if both of you wanted to because Allah
is merciful next
um offing people the process of never
often ends in person bring one example
of him offering an innocent person and
and inshallah you know Allah
I don't know do a backflip for you or
something you guys if you want to see
around me do a backflip come on now
produce your evidence but I mean you
remember that troll you went back and
forth with like a few months ago almost
a year ago and we even made a clip of
that well that was Slavic drill well
welcome back man may Allah guide you
I mean yeah
anyways um moving on they're always
watching eh yeah I mean alhamdulillah
let them watch maybe inshallah one day
Islam onto their heart
but I guess maybe we'll take so
everyone's asking for
host snakeo and Don um
problematic man I'm just saying like
these red pill these red pill guys like
there's just so much I don't know maybe
we'll respond to zerko one day and some
of his red pill beliefs and bro we
literally talked about manners and
that's
that's completely the opposite right
there yeah the absolute opposite I um
I think people I really want to speak to
um would be young Don Judy on those two
like in terms of novices those two are
on kind of my my list of people to speak
to inshallah
yeah I wonder where young Don lives I'm
gonna hit that in person podcast yeah
inshallah I understand also on sorry I
understand also Circa used to be a
stand-up comedian so the fact that he is
now
essentially if you guys know the Andrew
Schultz type of humor it's like pushing
the boundaries and crossing the lines
it's funny but it's like it's literally
for the intention of crossing the line
that's zirka before even getting into
red pill so now you have that Persona
combined with him kind of unplugging
himself and red pilling himself so it's
kind of what you're gonna get
unfortunately
and then I got them all along I mean
somebody asked um
thoughts on brother Ruslan he's the
Christian guy I think I'm sure you guys
seen him on how we reacted to his
response with his friend to uh to snico
I think he's a good guy I think he's
Fair I've been wanting to speak with him
for a while and and we're in
communication so we talk here and there
and he asked me a few questions about
stamina and that stuff yeah I would love
to see
[Music]
talking about this whole
the Trinity deal because I know Ruslan
he believes in the trinity
someone commented if I'm Lucid is coming
soon inshallah in person in
the works
that is the plan
um but aside from that I think we're
probably getting close to ending off the
stream so let's get final thoughts
inshallah
boys and girls
this Sunday 1 pm EST next stream
inshallah it's gonna be hot make sure
you guys tune in
so hard I didn't even know what's
happening this Sunday so I don't even
know what's up bro but any any t3m
stream is going to be popping inshallah
inshallah it's like may Allah bless you
all immensely unhill any final words
before we end off the Stream
okay take your time
I'll try lifting my hands up but then I
hit the mic and I was like oh no
but I just put my fingers just a little
bit just like that
all right
I guess inshallah we are good to end it
off and with that being said
inshallah we'll see you guys in the next
one